i honestly thought that said tigger
presents and now i'm just mad that it
won't be as bouncy trouncy flouncy
pouncy or as fun fun fun fun fun
taking 10 full seconds to reveal a
spacecraft i get we're going with a
theme here but our conjoined star
destroyer is really practical wouldn't
it limit the maneuverability and
increase vulnerability to attack what's
the practical benefit of this design
handprint walking waiting walking hand
print eyeball excitement
where are the guardrails on this skinny
bridge was there some sort of protest
against guard rails in this version of
the empire what kind of culture would
find such a simple effective action to
protect against unnecessary lives being
lost to be controversial can you even
imagine
our first introduction to the sister is
a crotch shot with a body sweep and i
demand to go back and see the same
introduction of the brother character
this is our mission as twins created
through the power of the dark side whoa
whoa whoa if you're gonna spend two
minutes on a spacecraft reveal and some
guy walking to a gemstone you can slow
down here during important explanations
and give us more time to see how the
these twins came to be and why they're
important will the weapons firepower be
at full strength rather than answering
this question with a yes b20n launches
into a visual explanation complete with
schematics and extra details about armor
that were fully unnecessary high purity
energy must be extracted from our power
source in the central core it's not a
star wars story until some droid has to
expose it the inner workings of a new
space weapon and considering all these
stories are sign stories that aren't
even official parts of lore it's not
even info i can store in my brain for
later use to show up my nerd friends
this isn't even a cannon cannon i am
concerned about the effect this
prototype dark armor could have on your
physical body as well as that of your
brother i mean you could worry about the
effect that the crystal could have on
the armor theoretically or you could
spend some time working out that karee's
very real mid-section lacks actual
protection you know according to this
neat chart do you ever look at the
designs of helmets and start off
wondering what the [ __ ] anyone was
thinking with the design and then
transition to justifying its shape
because of anatomical needs but then
finally decide that it's a clever
lunchbox and thermos storage yeah me
either
because looking across a vast distance
through a window to see an empty chair
on the adjacent starship is super normal
they won't find us
character confidently says something
won't happen and then it immediately
happens cliche
the twins are the two most powerful
people on the gemini-class star
destroyer created by the dark side are
these stormtroopers really surprised by
their power the most shocking part of
this episode is that either kari didn't
hear this small army approaching until
the lights came on or that the small
army assembled quietly against the wall
and began advancing in synchronistic
fashion as soon as the lights came on
using atsds in a ship or anywhere really
get out of here with your clumsy useless
atsd star wars we aren't buying it where
were you planning on going with that car
to a galaxy far far away you can't see
this but my eyes just rolled so far back
into my head that i think they're stuck
there guess i won't be needing this
anymore or this city more also is this
really the best way to remove your armor
or was this a self-destruct button that
has been waiting to be pressed since the
armor tailor explained its function now
in case of dramatic emergency press this
button in the armor will fly off in
multiple directions to reveal the very
basic clothing underneath so be sure you
strike a dramatic pose otherwise it will
be entirely too lackluster the galactic
empire or the republic
i couldn't care less about either one of
them star wars haters or fans i honestly
can't tell the difference anymore so you
have a bad feeling about this are you
kidding me i like being fan serviced as
much as the next guy but this episode
seems to think fanservice is just saying
things from the movies with little to no
added context it's like i always say the
ability to speak does not make you
intelligent she's going for the power
core she's going for the power core the
most powerful item on the ship the item
that fuels weaponry and armor the one
you just stole you don't say
now come to me
kyber sex also did someone decree that
every single one of these shorts had to
revolve around kyber crystals why i'm
just gonna say it cyber crystals are the
middle chlorians of lightsaber lore
don't add at me do you think i fear
death no but you clearly fear a nuanced
vocal performance sheesh turn it down
princess brea must i remind you of the
purpose of your birth i get the
impression that ammo reacts to just
about every situation with a reminder of
their dark purpose out of toothpaste
must i remind you that dental hygiene
supports our health which only enhances
our ability to fulfill the dark purpose
of our birth and go do it with the power
of the dark side flowing through my body
cool good thing your dark armor just
happens to have a built-in kybergyna for
just such an occasion
honestly not sure if i had to guess i'd
say that your iron spider armor
lightsaber whips got twisted around your
brother's new pepsi clearsaber it's okay
i'm sure the rest of this battle will
make much more sense before we go on can
someone explain the aesthetically
pleasing debris field do the twins have
pretty proximity powers for pretty space
junk patterns look i want to take a sign
off for how gorgeous some of this is but
it's just a jumble of nonsense she
launches a heel saber at him for yoda's
sake congratulations you somehow just
made heels even more impractical
duo's ex machina also breathing in space
talking in space and not immediately
freezing in space the hyperdrive
maybe that's right his plan will be to
use his massive op lightsaber combined
with the hyperdrive of the ship to
strike a pinpoint accurate blow to her
kyber cleavage at hyperspeed as one does
you're right our duo it's just like you
say
there is no try only do
as long as you're alive then you are
free i swear the writer of this had the
star wars imdb quotes open in one tab
and chicken soup for the soul open in
another and just alternated between them
for this finale
see
the precision of the tip of this
lightsaber spark managing to not slice
am in half and also delicately boot
blasting the crystal to nothingness is
some of the most [ __ ] free of
[ __ ] i've ever seen in other words
this [ __ ] works the visual echoes of
the holdo maneuver here are spectacular
but that just makes me think of a much
better star wars property the last jedi
which is almost unanimously considered
by star wars fans to be either the best
or second best star wars film of all
time as i'm sure the comments are
backing up right now with
well-considered and polite discourse
because the android needs an oxygen
helmet in space but the dark side duo
does not based on this visual the
lightsaber blast split the ship in twain
so did her armor save her from being
divided into and if her armor was strong
enough to repel his saber attack why
would the armor's only weakness be the
compartment designed to hold the
precious power source none of this makes
any sense she's somewhere out there the
key
to understanding our purpose the reason
why we were created how does am know
their purpose but khari doesn't do they
send those zoom invites to the wrong
email is swolesaber69 at empiremail.com
so hard to remember she's somewhere out
there beneath the clear blue sky if we
don't get five in a star wars movie soon
we riot she's alive
i can feel it and we're happy that the
power hungry murderess is out there
episode does not contain a
schwarzenegger or devito
that's right
he's not drake he's
hans ramore drake's evil twin using
sophisticated techniques they extract
the preserved blood from the mosquito
and
bingo
dino dna as you wish
that day she was amazed to discover that
when he was saying as you wish
what he meant was i love you
i'm feeling better so i'm running
errands i'm gonna get
no
some
tofu
i'm you no
i'm you yes that's what i mean
we're twins
must i remind you of the purpose of your
birth you were born to be hockey players
the darkening corrupts everything it
touches
nanowires feed directly into my
cerebellum
[Music]